all seasons of Entrepreneurship have
elements of loneliness and I think that
it changes I think in the beginning it's
a lot harder because you're really
competitive you're really competitive
against other people rather than being
competitive against yourself started
doing weight loss just for a few weeks a
buddy of mine who was in weight loss
came up to me and said yo if you do
weight loss we can't be friends he was
doing like 150 Grand a month I was like
dude it's a 60 billion dollar industry
like we can't both do weight loss he's
like dude I was doing weight loss first
I say that because like it sounds
ridiculous and that guy ended up
becoming very very successful and he
like later on was like dude I was just I
don't know sorry because you're so
afraid it's just fear if you can serve
your customers you'll have business it
doesn't matter what the competition's
doing and the Market's so big I think
that's why it's lonely but like it's
lonely at my point just in a different
way it's lonely because there's just not
that many people that I can talk to who
are you know dealing with the same
things